hello everybody and welcome to another
chest opening video today we're going to
be opening up ogre coffins now um the
ogre coffin has a bunch of moderately
valuable drops mainly in their bones um
so I'm going to open up 1,000 ogre
coffin Keys I've already bought them it
took about a day and a half to buy all
of them so not too bad to buy them and
we'll see if we can uh profit from it
from my first glance uh it does seem
like like I should profit some money but
it's kind of hard to say um because it
can vary quite a bit on the price we
sell the items for as well as our luck
pretty well anyway hope you guys enjoy
and let's get started all right guys so
we did manage to buy 1,000 ogre coffin
keys this only took about 2 days I
thought it would take longer but uh they
ended up buying very quickly on the
second day so 1,000 keys at 1753 each uh
we'll see have to see if that's actually
profitable or not not anything else
you're going to want is just the
graceful set and H some rings of dueling
we're going to want as well because it's
closest to Castle Wars and that's where
we're going to be teleporting to uh so
we'll just withdraw a ring of dueling
here and head on over to Castle
Wars and I think I'm going to bring 14
in the inventory first and see how many
or how many slots get filled up anyway
uh so yeah we'll draw 14 ogre Keys all
right we got 14 keys out from here I
believe believe we just run south and
we're going to be going back to jiggas
uh just close to the quest marker is
where the chest is or the coffin
anyway and uh now I'm not really sure
how profitable this is going to be or if
it is at all um because While most of
the drops are useless some of them are
quite valuable mainly the bones and now
that we're here here are the two coffins
I believe you can open them up
simultaneously so just use a key on the
coffin it'll give you a reward so some
Zer bones and then we'll use a key on
the other coffin and um oh wait what
yeah okay and a leather body I don't
know where we picked that one up for but
either way we're getting a couple things
all at once uh so it looks like you're
going to get more than one item on
average and looks like I'm getting a
bone pretty frequently and Rusty sword
wow that's actually a good way to get
the rusty
sword Roger
bones so we'll just do a full inventory
here and see if
um it'll fill our inventory
properly looks like we're getting
roughly two items AG go and almost
consistently some sort of
Bones so it seems like you get a bone
every
time oh not that time
actually some
nails so it might be considered or might
be worth dropping some of these like the
rusty swords aren't worth anything
neither are a lot of these drops the
coin drops not worth much either so we
might bring a couple more keys than just
the two
but anyway let's go ahead and price
check it
here approximately worth
14k um and the ogre bone there being a
large portion of that uh so yeah we'll
go ahead do a couple runs here and see
how much it's going to be worth and
we'll come back in a minute all right so
here is the ogre coffin drop table now
most of these drops uh that aren't the
bones are pretty worthless uh not any
notable jobs except for I guess the
laddin time that's worth a bit the bones
is pretty much worth all of the profit
or loss is going to come from um so Zer
bones you have a 50% chance of getting
well apparently while it seems to be
much higher chance of getting that I'm
not quite sure yet um 10% chance of
getting fager
bones 7.6% chance of getting rer bones
and but a 4% chance of getting a or bone
which is worth 25k now uh we'll do one
more run here it doesn't seem like the
first two runs I profited on but it
might take while for the RNG to kind of
balance itself out um so we brought a
little more keys this time let's price
check them first so they price checking
at about
25k that being said we did pay a bit
more for those uh if we start opening up
the
coffins so only a couple of the bones
we're going to profit
on and I think if we just click here
back and forth it'll automatically open
what else is in there so we got a far
bone hey we got a rag bone and then
another one so we got pretty lucky on
this run so far another far bone there
we
go wow we're getting pretty damn lucky
on this run so we'll probably profit
this time for sure so this is what a
good run will actually look
like all right and two Rusty swords as
well so that's a very common drop and
there we go silar bones so let's go and
price check this inventory then so 32k
now o buddy is only 4K of course A lot
of these bones don't trade a lot mainly
let's see Rock bone okay that's not the
most expensive one but uh still profited
off of this run so we're going to go
ahead and we have 1,000 Keys like I said
we'll stop in maybe halfway and kind of
do a temperature check see while we're
looking at as far as profit goes and
actually we should be teleporting back
to Castle Wars so um yeah we'll have to
see this could be close we might break
even or we're definitely going lose some
money but we'll see anyway we'll come
back in a little bit all right we're
just coming up to halfway through all of
the keys now we've gotten 12 ogre bones
so far or bones sorry uh 32 rag bones 51
farg bones and
252 Zer bones so in total we're looking
at about
350 bones it's pretty close now I
haven't gotten as many org bones as I
would have liked it says a roughly 3.75%
so close to four and I would be looking
at more like 20 so we're a bit behind
there but we're going to keep at it
we're doing 17 bones at a time and a
couple other things I've learned on how
to do this a little bit quicker is um
you don't actually have to click key or
click the coffin key and use it on the
coffins you can just Spam click them and
you can get through the keys pretty
quickly I think my most profitable run
so far was 100K uh cuz I got three of
the org bones you want to call it yeah
so all you have to do is really just
Spam click them you don't even have to
use the keys and I just hit the space
bar bunch and you can kind of open them
up actually pretty quickly um so yeah
about 23k is the cost of the keys and
we'll see how much we profit of this run
just for the LOLs and I don't really
think I've gotten any other valuable
drop we've gotten the grimy lentine a
couple times but he there's another or
bone nice um and yeah we'll see how much
we profited off of this
run Ah 69k that's pretty good um yeah so
I don't know I'm I'm really not certain
about this guys most of the chests I
open I'm pretty sure after the first 10
or 15 minutes if it's going to be
profitable or not but this one I am not
sure so stick around to the end and
we'll finish up the rest of the keys all
right we are just finishing up our very
last inventory here uh We've nearly done
all 1,000 uh I actually kind of enjoyed
this I don't know why it wasn't too bad
once you got into the rhythm of clicking
on the chest quickly uh the 1,000 by
pretty quickly I'd say you could get
this done in probably an hour and a half
if you're clicking properly and focusing
and uh 500 in an hour would be easily
doable that being said this took me
about 2 hours and we'll have a look at
how close our results were to the wiki
now the wi isn't 100% red all the time
of course but it's a good guideline and
um I I'm still really not sure if we're
going to profit here um when you get a
good run you make 50 to 100K even
sometimes um but the bad run is like a
20K loss so it's kind of hard to tell we
got another ug ug bone you want to say
that and that's it so let's head back to
Castle Wars and compare how many items
we got and how many we probably should
have
got all right let's have a look so we
ended up with Wow 500 on the dot Zer
bones so that is exactly 50% uh we got
114 Fay fogger bones so
11% 69 rogger bones which is about 7%
and org bones we got about 30 so 3% so
quite a bit less on those everything
else seems about in line Rog bonees
7.6% we got h a little bit less than the
average uh Zer bones 50% we got that
pretty much right on that nail um far
bones are a 10%
chance overdid that one a little bit so
we got more far bones than we were
supposed to and yeah let's withdraw the
stuff we'll sell off all the useless
stuff and then we'll make we obviously
we're going to take the time to sell
these bones cuz they are not traded very
frequently uh yeah we'll meet you at the
G all right guys we are at the Grand
exchange now if you recall we did buy
all the ogre coffin keys for 1.7 mil
roughly um so let's go ahead and price
check of course it's going to take a
while to sell but we'll get a rough
estimate for how much he should be worth
so we'll start by putting in the junk
now we'll just instant sell this
probably altogether it's probably only
worth like 10K or something steel
pickaxes look at this
crap and the nails might be worth a
little bit wait something here is worth
oh actually the black nails can add up
never mind
now for the important stuff 500 Zer
bones is going to be equal to about
316k roughly the fogger bones are 592k
brings us up to about 1 mil the rogger
bones brings us up to 1.5 mil as of
always buy price is a lot lower so we'll
have to see about that and the urg bones
brings us up to 2.3 mil or 1.4 mil as of
the OS buddy
prices amazingly enough I'm still not
sure if we're going to lose money or not
so let's go ahead and price check these
and get them into sell all right so we
sold off all the junk in our inventory I
don't know what happened here somehow I
instantly sold all of the r bones like
who the [__] is buying these but anyway
we'll leave that in there for now but we
put the offers in for 22k for the UR
bones uh 700 each for the Zer bones and
4 4450 for the far bones and the black
nails it's going to take a while to sell
these so I'll probably be back in a
couple days and I we finally get to
figure out if we actually made any money
so we see you then all right so finally
all of the fogger Bones have sold they
took the longest by far um followed then
by the Zer bones and the rag bones
anyway we finally got that sold that
took a long time so let's collect these
slowly if you recall we spent 1.7 mil on
the ingredients or the keys coffin keys
and let's see if we're going to
profit so 1.7 mil we got to make are we
going to get
it I think we yeah we're actually going
to profit nice so we started with 1750k
and we're going to end
with
2150 so about 400k in profit which is
actually pretty good uh it's not a very
good hourly rate and while you could
probably get this done in an hour and a
half uh the length that took to sell the
items as well as the
unpredictability I guess of the prices
would make this not a very good money
maker but still interesting to see if
it's actually profitable to open the
coffins uh all right guys hope you
enjoyed uh if you did I would appreciate
if you left a suggestion for maybe
another chest opening or something
similar uh any other random obscure
chest in the game I'd like to go have a
look at and see if the keys are
profitable to open just kind of more of
my own curiosity all right guys guys see
you in the next video